I think I've always been pretty aware of
what I'm good at and not good at and not
shied away from that aside from that I
don't think at any point I was if I'm
honest was thinking Ki I need a business
partner I probably totally undervalued
the impact that a business partner could
have welcome back to another episode of
the recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host hea mazus and in this week's
episode I was joined by Abby done she's
the founder of 68 people and she runs a
specialist Hospitality recruitment bus
and then entered the co Madness and new
world is Hospitality the bottom of the
bottom yeah so it was you know one of
the the most impacted Industries mhm in
2020 their turnover was 122,000 and
there's five people in the business in
2021 that grew to 464,000 and9 people in
2022 that grew to just over a million
and 14 people and 2023 1.7 with 24
people and they're on track to break the
2 million Mark what I love about this
story and the passion that Abby has is
her entire commitment to delivering a
client and candidate experience that is
exceptional she's one of the very few
leaders that speaks about experience
non-stop one of their cool kpis within
their business is net promoter score
their fi rate is extremely high and they
want to make it even better how how do
you uncover people that align with your
values in the interview process yeah
it's hard and you kind of always think
God how can we enjoy this week's episode
Abby welcome back to the podcast thank
you very much thanks for having me so we
we sat down in uh November 2020 when our
conversation went out yeah so by then
you were you had your F you had a first
four year in business cuz you started in
2019 mhm and then entered the co Madness
and new world is Hospitality the bottom
of the bottom yeah so it was you know
one of the the most impacted Industries
MH so I've always like outside looking
in I've always like really found how
you've approached things really
interesting like on The Branding front
the values just just how you've gone
about your business so while I was
really Keen to you know have you back on
the Pod is you know I think know safe to
say you've really gone on this growth
Journey not just I'm not just talking
about headcount Revenue just I think you
really evolved your business M over the
last like three years so I think today
that's what we're going to be uncovering
cuz I think there's going to be a ton of
learnings for current recruitment
Founders aspiring recruitment Founders
on some of the things that you've
implemented that you've learned that
you've executed which I think a lot of
people can learn from cuz I know you you
don't you don't you know paint yourself
with the brush of like I'm a typical
recruitment found like you're typical
recruitment
founder I'll ask you that at the end to
see what you think okay Okay cool so
let's just give everyone some immediate
context so if I get any of this wrong
yes just let me know okay yes so the
some of the key metrics so 2019 turnover
305 there's three of you 2020 122 there
was five of you uh 2021 that increased
to 464 and there was nine people in the
business but five billers 2022 um just
over million 1. um76 14 people in the
business nine billers and then 2023 1.7
in turnover 24 people in the business 15
in uh billers and 2024 goers to break
the 2 million Mark which is really
exciting and you've put I'm you've put
24 and 15 again so I'm assuming you're
you're like aiming to do that with the
same amount of people currently yeah I
think next year for us is you know
making the people that we've got in the
team better focusing on training and
development love that so one of the
things are really interesting that you
kindly shared to me was uh the you know
core of your business is recruitment M
but then you've got these other uh you
know products called class of 68 uh you
got International um part of your
business that's growing and you got
consultancy so consultancy is 5%
International 9% class 6 8% yeah so Keen
to go into that and then I guess the
final bit of context which I think would
be useful for people is uh and again you
can let me know if I'm wrong here but I
ask you like what what's aby's role now
um and I think this would be useful for
context so you have a business partner
called Charlotte which we're going to go
into because that's been quite pivotal
and then you know the couple of bullet
points we put under yourself is you
spend a lot of your time coaching
training the existing team involved in
marketing the BD strategy just
strategically thinking about how you can
keep moving forward as a business and
you're always thinking about how you can
improve the candidate and client
experience yeah yeah that's what I lose
sleepover for sure all right cool so
let's let's start with a million pound
question then in your in your opinion
what are the the characteristics and
traits of uh successful recruits in
today's
market
um well there's a few isn't there I
definitely think look if you if you
can't prioritize your work effectively
and you can't work at speed and have
this kind of sense of urgency
recruitment's probably not for you um
we've certainly found over the years
that this emotional resilience to
decisions that are made um helps you
know we probably a few years ago now I
was noticing people being you know
pretty emotional about decisions that
clients are making or candidates are
making like we can't we can't operate a
business like this um so we brought into
this kind of cause and effect principle
that you know as long as a very like
self-reflective I think we're a very
self-reflective business and I think
that the Consultants that do really well
the ones that are constantly saying what
could I have done differently um or they
getting to a point of off a stage of
saying okay I've done everything I can I
know I've done everything I can I've
referenced my experience was great I've
not I'm not putting the square pegs into
round holes and that point if the
decision doesn't go your way you know
it's cool I think this emotional roller
coaster that we were on was a challenge
at one point so so yeah this definitely
um not we I don't think we have a blame
culture around blaming consultants and
candidates for decisions and I think
that can create a shitty culture so from
my point of view that's a really good
behavioral trait that we need to have um
and I think you know we've got to be
we've got to be experts and that's not
always easy when you start in
recruitment to be an expert but to me
the expert
isn't about telling it's not about
saying to a client this is what I think
in actual fact I don't I think a lot of
the time a client won't give a
about your opinion I think you've got to
coach them you've got to question them
and you know yeah we can drop in our
expertise but actually you know a lot of
we're talking to a lot of people
directors and operations directors who
have got significantly more experience
in their field
so I think being influential an expert
but without being a knob is is a pretty
good trait of a recruiter yeah I really
like that em I really like that
emotional bit that you're talking about
because I think that can just help you
in life yeah like not not uh yeah not to
be the first person to point the finger
at other people yeah and you've got to
be careful because you can't come across
that you don't give a either
there's the other way around of yeah
whatever it doesn't matter it does
matter um but I think yeah it's pretty
liberating to constantly be reflecting
thinking what could I have done
differently rather than trying to manage
other people's behaviors um I certainly
you know found that for the last few
years when I've kind of adopted this
technique myself no no honestly I love
that so much um a quote that all like
whenever I talk about stuff this a quot
that I always keep front in the mind is
whoever you poting the finger at you
give power to yeah and I think like even
in like in recruitment if you're always
putting the finger at the client and
candidate it's going to be a pretty
rough time um yeah and how do you
improve right like exactly you
can't self-reflecting thinking what can
I done differently gives you choice and
power to do things differently if you're
constantly thinking what did they do
wrong you know then you just stay at
this stay at basic level yeah definitely
Okay cool so couple of things I just
want to get straight into it with you if
that's okay so like we did a podcast
before so for anyone listening feel free
to go back and listen to that but we
sort of spoke about the first year in
business then Co happened so I want to
just go straight into a specific part of
this timeline of this journey which is
Charlotte joining basically yeah so
which was May 2021 yes right cuz I find
that really interesting uh just because
you know that year you had a solid year
of turnover and then you like overd
doubled the turnover the year before and
then you youve continued growing MH so
why don't why don't we just start with
what what would be really interesting
interesting for you to share is
obviously you started this business on
your own mhm like what were some of the
signs that kept showing up for you that
made you feel like hell if I
like I'm I really like the idea of
bringing someone in or if I just keep it
myself then I'm maybe not going to get
to where I want to I don't know but like
what were some of the signs that made
you to start think about someone like
Charlotte joining your business and
bringing them on the journey with you um
well I think I think I've always been
pretty aware of what I'm good at and not
good at and not shied away from that um
you know I don't really enjoy sitting in
rooms analyzing pnls the team will be
laughing
um but you know I know I've got
strengths um but aside from that I don't
think at any point I was if I'm honest
was thinking K I need a business partner
okay I probably totally undervalued the
impact that a business partner could
have um but Charlotte had been a friend
for many years and I knew her
capability uh and I suppose being
totally honest he was like oh I bet I
bet it'll be really fun really yeah yeah
which doesn't mind me saying that but I
knew she'd be great obviously
but um uh you know what do you think
would' be fun about it we're really good
mates and uh yeah we've we'd worked
together before in a previous life in
Hospitality um and I didn't it didn't
really enter my head any negative side
of it any maybe because you know I've
had to put some ego stuff aside for sure
during this journey um you know we she
we're we're business part Partners now
and um but the process the the benefits
that it's bought in terms
of the speed at which we can make
decisions um how you know that having
two different opinions and coming to a
conclusion just the level so much more
fun it is fun you know we we had a
strategy meeting yesterday and we were
both like super excited about it it's
just two of us sat in a room for nine
hours you know it's but and I didn't
have what I didn't know what I was
missing
you know I didn't know that that was
that was would be so cool no I can
relate I can relate to that like having
a 9-hour strategy session on your own is
fun with another person and even though
you can actively
share the the things that are in your
mind about your business and the journey
room with your partner your friends it's
it's not it's not the same like they
even though they could maybe be really
good listeners and go oh Abby that's
really interesting I understand they
don't yeah now you've got someone who's
on you know you're is in the boat with
you you're run in the same direction and
I totally get why that would be why that
would be more like I I get that yeah
being founder it is like we we share the
same values and that's um super
important would I advise people to go
and find a business partner that they'd
never worked with before I don't know
but um it you know we because we knew
each other so well and you know she's
brilliant at certain things and I think
she would say the same about me and you
know that what I do think is important
in that relationship is is trust and
yeah we you know we trust each other we
trust each other to do the right thing
for the business um I can't imagine how
it would be if we didn't didn't have
that I mean it would be obviously really
yeah so less interested in like the
nitty-gritty details but I think people
would be interested maybe people that
started their business on their own
actually have maybe thought about the
idea of bringing someone on if it is the
right person or that but the way that
you set it up is uh over a period of
time Charlotte just basically ears um
owns more and more of the business and
obviously you would agre like x amount
but over time as the business grows um
and length of service her like share in
the business Grows Right yeah yeah and
from her experience background like
Charlotte had not worked in recruitment
for she'd done recruitment but she her
her background was actually in
Hospitality in the niche that that we
work in so having that experience and
you know she'd she'd operated large
businesses so she brought a skill you
know that I I didn't have and I think
that's probably quite important to kind
of think about what you what you your
weaknesses are and find find someone
that can do that what is what was the
job spec I don't think I have a job spec
no but like what was like cuz I think
that'd be helpful to like what yeah okay
what ended up being I'm sure it's
evolved you told me some of the things
that fall under her remit but like
initially when you're bringing this
person in what are like the core things
you're like right these are the things
that that you're going to be respons for
going to be focusing on Char Charlotte
comes to the party with more kind of red
energy than than I have so she gets sh
done yeah so you know the kind of things
like immediate changes that were made
like it sounds small but a meeting
Cadence for example so now we do you
know since since Charlotte's joined um
you know we do everybody in the business
knows the their meeting review schedule
every meeting has got etiquette around
it so it's got an agenda it's got a time
scale it's got action points it's got
minutes that's a game changer like
that's because you get done um so
so operational processes yeah um I
suppose I I knew what best practice was
but I'd not written it down anywhere was
in my head you know um and so there's
been quite a lot of getting stuff out of
my head um to you know in into some kind
of Pro system or process uh and I think
um she saw quite quickly that in order
for the business to grow I needed to
come out of recruitment um uh you know
physically talking to to candidates and
and and having a billing Target for
example and that um she made that
possible by us having systems and
procedures in place that you know we
hadn't had before why did you think that
was important um because that that ties
you to I think that limits growth you
know the stuff that I work on now with
the team and from a more strategic
business I definitely spend a lot of
time working on the business rather than
in it and I know that's really tough
that's that was what I always found
tough and I definitely found it tough I
found it tough maybe stepping away
from clients or handing things over that
I'd held the Reigns of for so long um
but I can see now the beauty of doing
that okay that I that is interesting
that you go to something as like granula
as like a meeting CAD
I know yeah and that's huge the other
things for example with a team they've
got you know regular reviews a review
document I mean kpi is for another one I
always i' I remember writing a Blog I
can't remember if I mentioned this last
time about recruitment isn't a numbers
game and um yeah recruitment is a
numbers game you know I came out of
quite a big agency and thought hate it
hate the numbers hate the number of
calls number of calls but actually you
know you can't prove anything unless you
measure it mhm and as long as you
measure the right things at the right
time because measurements create the
culture um you know we talk for example
a lot about fill rate um we talk a lot
about NPS so and Charlotte's been able
to see that from a different angle to me
and you know from a more operational
kind of generic good business angle as
opposed to having years of been
indoctrinated by other you know
recruitment practices um and so that's
been really beneficial I think where
what we've seen over the last few years
and what's supported growth is where
where we measure stuff like what we
measure um like for example like if we
measure if we purely measure Revenue the
behavior that that kicks out is shiness
right you just want to we just we're
just going to do what we can to get
Revenue if we purely measure CV sends
I'm going to do send as many as a can
and the quality will be so it's
real real consideration of where we
accelerate and push on what we should
measure and what that behavior kicks out
we talk about that a
lot okay just before I want to go into
that but Ju Just quickly you sort of
highlighted it but there'll be a lot of
people listening to this that manage a
team lead a team run a business and have
meetings I I can relate to that as well
so the fact that you led with that
clearly you feel that's had a big impact
so I just want to make sure that for
people listening they can maybe consider
implementing some of these things so how
how did your meetings run before
Charlotte joins you said the meeting
Cadence you mentioned the weekly reviews
minutes just give us the Gran of things
on like how they run before and how they
run now with Charlotte involved and and
why the the net positive of
that we'd have meetings um I'd probably
if I'm honest um you know it would be
quite easy for me to move them and now
that you know that doesn't that wouldn't
happen and I can see the benefit in that
um but I think so for example we'd have
meetings and we'd we we would maybe
float around about subjects and and you
can kind of become obsessed about
certain detail and then you know the
meeting runs over blah blah blah you
kind of bringing the whole team into
meetings where that's unnecessary maybe
that was linked to the size at the time
um but certainly um Charlotte had come
from uh um an organization that that had
kind of cadences in place um so the
changes that we made were for example
now we we meet with the leaders every
Monday morning at 9:30 so that's the
leaders meeting then the leaders going
to their meetings 10:30 till 11: um
everybody's got uh there's an agenda set
agenda every week same agenda so you
know whatever that might be candidates
at final um we talk about what's what
really important to the meeting is we
open it with value highlights and um
highlights from the week before and kind
of people that have exhibited our values
you know like shout outs value shout
outs so that's set you know Monday
morning I know people some people
disagree with early Monday morning
meetings but that sets a really nice
tone for you know it's not just straight
into numbers we talk we're really
transparent with com business Revenue
over the whole business so there's a
transparency there although it's not a
so so we talk about it a lot um we then
you know we're going to talk about areas
of focus for everybody and candidates at
final that message and then gets
transcended into the next you know the
leaders going into their
teams um everybody we
do um monthly reviews with the
consultants and then quarterly reviews
with the leaders um we do by annual
conference um and again it links to
Cadence we've got a set format for each
thing so we do um mentoring sessions
where some of the team have mentoring
mentors within the business um but
everybody knows that they've got this
set set number of times that we
communicate as an as a office we've got
two offices one in Manchester one
another so we communicate as an office
communicate on a onetoone basis and
communicate as a company um and I think
that brings a calmness right people know
what's expected and what's happening I
appreciate you sharing that I find that
super interesting cuz definitely guilty
I mean there's four of us but guilty of
moving like one on ones and certain
things so there's like but when when
what I've definitely found because I've
recently implemented a different meeting
which is like a specific meeting with
sales with marketing with customer
success and like when meetings go well
they you feel really good about them in
terms of like when you feel they're
productive yeah that like I think
there's so many meetings happening
across just businesses in general
recruitment businesses where people walk
up and go that was a waste of
time yeah I we can't always stick to it
but I know I've got about 50 minutes of
mental capacity when it comes to meeting
um and so I I do struggle after that and
so I appreciate that other people must
do as well but I think that the the bit
that where you get done is the
action points and and saying who's going
to do what by when and they reviewed you
know Charlotte and I for example will
have a monthly board meeting and have
action points from that and they're
reviewed when we come back in um so yeah
I do I mean it sounds pretty boring
doesn't it meeting Cadence but it's
pretty big been an impactful yeah yeah
so what I'm going to go into next and is
how you've set up your business cuz it
is it is different okay I would say in
in the I'm going to take that as a
compliment the BD function the talent
Consultants like how you set that up I
find that that interesting yeah was it
when did it when did it evolve like that
was it in 2021 it started like that um
I'd I suppose when we set up I'd always
done the business development personally
and had the Consultants um there was
never I knew when I went into another
agency the bit that I hated about the
job was the cold calling part that
people wanted you to do and um I didn't
want to do it and I you know I just
didn't have that in my I didn't didn't
want to do it so I was really
appreciative that actually people that
that might join us and if I'm selling
this as a great opportunity for people
to join and they suddenly landed with
something that they don't want to do
I've never done before we've got a
slightly different model that we take on
people from Hospitality operations yeah
um so I was doing all the BD at first
and then as we grew that became you know
that that was unsustainable but I always
knew that um if we got to a certain
point I would separate out that function
I knew it was a different skill I knew
that um the focus I wanted the
consultant's focus to be on Cent
experience existing client experience
and candidate experience that's where I
wanted them to spend their time to love
what they do um uh and and so yeah we
we've um we knew that that business
development function was was unique and
needed to be done by a different team So
currently we have two head of client
success they're they're called now um
we've had a tweak there but they will be
responsible for taking new
clients through a sales Cadence um and
then um they do what we call Discovery
call so they at that point kind of
diagnose the challenges of the business
find out what how we can help and then
that will get passed on to either the
recruitment team um the biggest part of
the business or if um you know if it's a
training need that they've got we can
pass that on to we've got a Training
Division or if it's an international
challenge so they need um specific
International Talent then it goes to
that division um
you know we're evolving all the time so
we're now questioning as an organization
whether that those two girls both called
we've got five abies in the business bus
five hell um Abigail and Abby
spelled differently to me um uh whether
they're going to have some involvement
in account management of of of bigger
clients and I think that's probably
going to be the next step because the
way that you've done it was they got a
percentage of revenue for the first six
months yes client that they brought on
yeah
let's I I I love this approach by the
way because I just love the fact that
even the fact that you've got Discovery
calls in there yeah like so many
recruiters don't have that step yeah cuz
you know my my world is training and
we've done a bunch of training stuff on
this and a lot of people don't do that
cuz what I really love what you just
mentioned there is they're trying to
diagnose problems yeah right and a lot a
lot feels better to do that yeah but
also it's given you yes aing you to have
an opportunity to truly understand what
their problems are so you can you know
offer the the best
solution yeah and we've got a from day
door we've got to come across like we're
experts and if we start talking about
vacancies and roles what jobs you got
you know it's transactional and we'll be
treated like you know and um I've
when I've been when we when we've not
had a great client relationship it's
because you know reflecting um it's
because I've gone in as some kind of
subservient yes sir no sir but you know
we'll do anything we'll work on whatever
jobs you want um and now I have a
totally different attitude to that yeah
um honestly I love it I think this is
one step in a process that if recruiters
were supported in effectively
implementing this it would have a big
impact 100% like a sound B I've said
multiple times on here and she always
drop me a note say mention me on the Pod
but I think it sums up perfectly so we
had um uh we had a got she was at the
she was on the panel of our maner event
Amber Penrose right I watched it she was
Fab yeah so she did a training session
with us and what I always remember
saying is what made her go from the 400
Grand biller to a 8900 Grand biller was
she stopped chasing vacancies and she
only chased problems yeah right and like
we spoke about her process where the
first step is at Discovery call and
that's where you're saying look yes I
understand you have roles vacancies we
can talk about them but first in order
for me to be honest with you and advise
where I can help I need to understand
understand where you're at how we got
here why why is it important you get
this person what happens if you don't
get this person what have you tried so
far what hasn't worked what has worked
like you need to understand you got to
stop people talking about the vacancy
actually you got to push back because
the client might want to jump into that
but you've got you know we definitely
find we want to push back and go just
The other reason we push back is because
we've we've got two different teams of
people that they're going to have a
conversation with so they're going to
have a discovery call and then they're
go to have a roll brief with the
recruitment team and we're really
conscious that they that it can't be
telling the same thing twice so we've
got to really separate okay Discovery is
is more strategic you know what how can
we help and then Ro brief is right okay
tell me about the behaviors and
responsibilities in this job this
podcast is proudly partnered with Viner
the all-in-one recruitment agency
software that over 20,000 recruiters
trust daily we're also partnered with
the award-winning oneup sales the sales
a motivation platform that enables you
to maximize the potential of your teams
we love partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10% of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode all right
let let I think this will be helpful for
people so I just want to dive into this
a little bit okay so so you got two
people that basically their entire
purpose is to bring on new clients yeah
and the the the process is they have a
sales Cadence that they follow that
enables them to have the best
opportunity best chance of booking and
Discovery CES yeah how long is often a
discovery call 45 minutes 45 minutes so
they're asking for 45 minutes Discovery
call um and then curious them with what
you just said after that yeah obviously
they're then recommending the solution
mhm right whether that be well from what
I've learned today these are the reasons
why you should speak to our recruitment
team and why they're best position to
support you with your challenges or this
I'm going to introduce you to Abby who's
head of training from what you said
today this is why I'm doing that yeah in
between that on the recruitment side
yeah because a lot of people won't have
a r Training Division like are you
having terms signed in between that the
BD team agree the terms in Discovery yes
or they they will say at the end so the
talk through our process and at the end
of the call say I'm going to send you
the terms over um and then they'll have
that discussion yeah I mean they do that
in Discovery yes I was thinking that cuz
they're not going to have that job
briefing if surely if you haven't we
we've learned the lesson the hard way of
yeah we we don't go any further than
that until we've agreed terms okay um
all right so if I'm listening right now
MH the often push back that I've heard
from
people um
was yeah but
like I've got a client I've got a
company that has vacancies yeah that I
can start working on yeah and I need
help with them like I'm I going to miss
out if I say hey hey whoa whoa whoa wait
wait let let's have a discovery call
first and then we'll talk about the
roles like I might miss out I'll
challenge them on fill rate right
because the our fill rate I think is
significantly higher than a lot of other
contingent models you know we're hoping
next year to hit % fill rate um at the
moment it's 455 yeah yeah that's
definitely higher than yeah
so it's about the quality and it's about
how you if if you cut
Corners you know that that that behavior
is mirrored by the client and you will
be treated like a recruiter not as a
partner yeah and I don't want to be
treated like a recruit you know just a
yeah F this for me I want to offer a
professional service and that's about
taking time to you know it's it's a
significant cost for somebody I don't
want to it up so let's do it
properly so just two two final bits then
um one what's the typical uh like what's
what have you found to be the most
effective agenda for that Discovery
call um so um we've done some training
recently so we we talk um about we go
through success criteria for the
business and for their business we talk
very little I we we don't really talk
about us at all we'll talk maybe at the
end for one or two minutes like what I
think is a big change you know when I've
when I was inhouse and had recruiters
come to me and they get their bloody
deck out and you're like I I don't
really give a about your values or
your you know how nice you how good a
deck you can put together you know like
a 20page deck like come on um so we we
we took took the whole all the steps
really are about their business and the
challenges they're facing what's their
Vision um what what experience they've
had before with other recruitment
businesses why they're at that
challenging Point um talking about then
how we might be able to help them and
then I suppose we we then create a bit
of a sense of urgency with putting a
plan in in terms of REO this is if you
wanted somebody um if you wanted this in
place by then this would be the reverse
engineering what dates we would need to
start our process is pretty laid out as
well we know that it takes us between
eight and 10 working days to create a
short list we know that um on average
people have between four and six weeks
notice so we can pretty much predict
when we can we know that interview stage
takes two weeks yeah so that's a really
good kind of way of putting that out um
and then you know we don't hide away
from the fact at the end that the client
might need to go and do something like
write a job description like you know
and that's we then summarize the call
and um talk about what we need to go and
do and what they need to go and do yeah
um and it look we're changing this all
the time but we've learned this the hard
way of doing me really getting really
excited about a new sexy brand or in
Hospitality that's hard as well because
yeah as a customer you know these Brands
and you think oh God that sounds great
really want to work with them um and
then you realize you've one of
four
agencies um they've got a big direct
team and you think actually this is this
is not a great client in terms of the
commercials it also helps you to like
have more clarity on that is a is this a
work yeah we do we're in the process of
the moment of qualifying clients um
intern
and that's that's not easy to do without
knowing yeah until you started working
with them we don't know how great
they're going to be at communication or
how they're going to be um what we
can do is qualify jobs fairly you know
we can qualify them by location uh you
know culture fit people culture salary
so we do have a measure of qualifying
jobs and we uh as a business think that
we should be spending our time on jobs
that score over seven out of 10 say say
that again s out of 10 yeah yeah yeah we
don't always do that because sometimes
that we can fill a three out of 10 job
and we really want the client or we've
got capacity so there's lots of
different factors at play but I think
having this consultant mindset of okay
if I need to prioritize my time I should
prioritize it on a seven out of 10 yeah
okay and I appreciate you sharing that
so very much focused about them and yeah
the reason for that is you're not going
to be able to come up with a solution if
you're talking most of the time right so
the the just on that what have you found
cuz this something I was looking at cuz
this is my process as well Discovery
cool again it's very much about them I
need to understand the problems why
we're here these things what we tried so
far what isn't working and then from
that I can then say well from what I've
learned today these are the reasons why
I think it'd be worth our time to like
progress to The Next Step but what have
you uh found to be like your um what I
want to say to be fair actually I was
going to ask you around your like
conversion from Discovery to then
signing cuz you've added that extra step
yeah do you know that figure or like
that conversion of done a discovery call
they've signed terms now they're a new
client I don't I don't know an exact
measure but I would say the reason we we
start measuring something when we've got
a good feeling there's a challenge and I
know it'll be above 90% you know it's
really good whether that converts into
Revenue you know sometimes you know it's
different yeah but I think that's cuz
the reason I'm Mar that is like people
might think oh that's just like not
worth the hassle rather just go straight
into the vacancy right if you're saying
majority of the time we sign terms we're
not saying that every single time that's
going to be you know 10 out of 10 job
but more often not even though we've
added that extra step whereas another
recruit just go straight in Abby tell me
about these you know general manager
jobs sounds great go to that yeah okay
we are up against that we're you know
and that is especially when we've come
down to London we're up against that
more and it's really hard to trust your
process um but I've got to believe
that's the right thing to do because
I've got to believe that we want better
client relationship sh and we want
better jobs to work on yeah and for
those of you listening you can showcase
that by your process yeah that I found
that like if I if I take you through a
sales process and you're impressed and
like you can you can you know stand out
just by implementing like a really solid
process even before you start working
together I could make your perception of
me wow these guys are really impressive
what is it going to be like when we stop
working with each other yeah you know
exactly and if somebody wants to do it
quick and dirty then maybe they're not
the right client for you anyway yeah so
just F FAL bit I know we going granted
there but that will be helpful for
people um
what's what's the me like what's like
the core message around why it's worth
your time Abby the hiring manager to
give me that 45 minutes like what what
have you found to be the most effective
message because in terms of what I would
say to a client yeah cuz like we're
talking about Pally now you're facing in
l
got for that let's just straight into
these J I've got sign off like let's
just get into it I just spoke to these
guys down the road like they've told me
that they can work on these I only want
to speak with one of our agency let's
just get straight into that and you're
going to hang on a minute let's why it's
saying look we we want to understand
that that you're right for us and we're
right for you um and it's setting
your you know it's setting that
messaging out that you are equal that
you're both com your time is as valuable
as their time time and you want to make
sure that if you're going to work in
this contingent fashion that you want to
know that they they're a decent operator
or that they you know operate in a
certain way so although you look I
understand you might not say that we
want to work out whether you're a good
client but that's that's ultimately what
you mean yeah okay cool and then so then
passed over to the recruitment team and
then you've got talent Consultants that
speak to
clients that manage processes but are
then entirely focused on speaking to
candidates growing uh getting the short
list together presenting them yes yeah
yeah so curious then how many I don't
this might not be something you measure
I was going to ask you how many stop
asking me that I don't measure
measure loads sorry sorry so I'm going
to ask you about the I want to go into
the experience but just final thing okay
okay two people like what how many
Discovery calls of these people
typically like what what's ended up
being um in a week um they I don't know
what their actual Target is but they
will have a Target um I I imagine
they're doing between 5 and 10 a week
okay cool nice experience then let's
talk about that yay I do meas this
sorry so and so I found it so
interesting and love the fact that one
of the core kpis is MPS
yes so obviously you're measuring and
that's you know a way for you to measure
client and candidate experience yeah um
so do you want to explain MPS for people
that cuz we use NPS on our our business
yeah um so we've we chose to use it
because we work in hospitality and it's
a real um key indicator it's ultimately
the the answer to would you recommend us
to a friend um and if you score nine or
10 you counted if you're seven or eight
you're passive and taken away and if
you're five and six you're detracted so
um we thought it was a relevant measure
because our clients would understand it
um
we approached it from the fact that look
we can easily if we want an ego measure
we can record MPS at placement stage so
we can ask candidates how did you find
us when we found you a great new job um
and we can ask clients how did you find
us when we found you somebody but
actually that is not the real way to
measure you know to to measure feedback
and if we're putting so much time and
effort and energy into consultant
training and development around
experience we need to measure it at
different points um so we measure it
throughout the candidate Journey whether
you get a job with us or not so as soon
as you've been put into any kind of
process you start you start receiving
feedback surveys um and as a client as
soon as you have gone through the
discovery and roll brief so before
you've ever had a candidate we start
asking you what you think um yeah okay
love that so both our candidate and our
client uh are over 90 yeah um which we
keep going back and going this can't and
I get people who fill out the survey
it's polarized you either fill out a
survey Because You Love a service or you
hate a service and but I think we you
know we we we do a good job and we've
become OBS you know we're obsessed
about this perception of recruiters and
making sure that we're offering you know
a really valuable service to our clients
and I know it sounds corny but
you know it is when you're talking to a
candidate it's the most Joy you can get
is finding them a job that improves
their life and well-being and you know
we've got we've got a team of people
that that's what they want to
do so just to paint a picture then we've
spoken a lot about the client side so
let's just focus on the candidate side
for a sec where often times it can the
experience can be like the ball can be
dropped yeah so if I go through a
process with you guys yeah um I I get uh
I um get registered I'm talking to you
about my experience you're telling me
you're qualifying me I've never use the
term registered okay so yeah you're
qualifying me um you then end up telling
me about one of the the jobs that you're
working on with with one of your compan
with one of the companies you're working
with and you then decide to go yeah you
know what heam I think we'd really like
to put you forward to this one yeah um
so then you put me forward I then get an
interview request uh I then have that
interview um I then don't get progress
to the next stage
mhm where how many times am I going to
be asked would you recommend 68 people
to a colleague or friend you've probably
been asked three times by then but if
you if you fill it in you don't get a
repeat survey um so once you filled it
in you don't get asked again you get
it's survey dependent so we've got like
a a Cadence of what what you you know
you wouldn't get asked the same question
TW same survey twice if you filled it in
um but just to go back slightly look at
we treat uh We've until this year um
we've actually spent the last two years
focusing on candidate experience so um
people candidates approaching us um have
a discovery call as well so their
Discovery call is about career
motivators and what's going on with them
you know what their a bit about what
their experience is really diagnosing
their problem so when we diagnose their
problem then we can work out whether
we've got solutions for them and I think
that is
that we we we're transparent and
sometimes we say to candidates look I'm
sorry you're great but I don't think
we've got something for you right now
we're going to um you know we create a
68 Locker for you so we create um a
space on the system I mean it's it's an
ATS um where we've got your motivators
in there and if we have anything that
comes up we we'll be in touch so at that
point we've not raised expectations that
say we're going to come back to you next
week so that's so I think that's the
first point second point is then if we
we always understanding from our client
Discovery call what our what the selling
points of that business is and they've
got to match those motivators like so we
we're kind of diagnosing right okay
could this company fit fit this
candidate um so we send them away to
look at a role at that point we then do
what we call a face to face so we would
then do like a range of Competency Based
questions based on what the clients
looking for um so they've spent
following that they there's another bit
and um convinced that this is like a key
differentiator in terms
of um candidate experience this
interview preparation you know we're not
sending on email your time and and um
you know who you're meeting it is kind
of really in depth of right tell me what
you think about what what do you love
about this business so we we're doing a
bit of mock interviewing or you know I
think it's like it's coaching it's
coaching people and I think that does
set we've got to find a way to set
people to set us apart in as a candidate
service we've got to give candidates a
reason to come back to us and keep using
us and actually if we're just going to
fly them through a process and go there
you go meet that person why the hell
would they ever come back to us so we've
got to protect that candidate experience
and say look whether you've got a job
through us or not we hope you've had a
great experience um and that interview
preparation I think um is is really
important we spend around you might
laugh at this around two hours with
every candidate before they get to a
client What
discovery on average 2 hours yeah oh
yeah I know yeah but you w you can't be
doing that unless your like what's being
the outcome of that is like posit NE not
positive yeah yeah yeah and look could
we make efficiencies there you know I I
challenge you to go and look at our
reviews and and see we should be
spending any less than hours I was going
ask you then I feel like You' dis
answered it I was going to ask
you like any anything like I feel like
it's more about I feel like you would
have got to that process that you just
described by like making slight changes
small processes time up do again yeah
exactly so so I was going to ask you
even though being aware it's probably a
bundle of like small changes over time
it's then resulted in that and then you
sort of maybe happy for it for a period
And it's like right what bit can we
change that I was going to ask you like
what have been some of the like big leav
you've pulled that you think has sort of
really had an impact on the 90% plus it
seems like you've really taken interview
coaching properly yeah intervie coaching
pce um
definitely what about not getting a job
I feel like that's where often times the
expence can be dropped yeah so feedback
look I think the
Consultants see that their relationship
with their or the business sees their
relationship with the candidate as a
kind of lifetime relationship um so that
is they might go through a a short
process with us but that's you know
there there still part of our Network
you know and and we see that as a that
we're trying to grow this big Network
and and you know we don't again it's not
transactional we don't want a candidate
to come in and then go to somebody else
when they're thinking about job hunting
in Hospitality that happens relatively
often um you know we want them to pick
up the phone to us we want them to think
I've got a care career coach and I've
got someone that's my pal I'm going to
pick up the phone and talk to um but
then that is a cultural thing about our
team and I think you know maybe a
separate conversation about how we live
our values and say what we do and don't
do as an organization that that makes
sure the team can deliver that to to
candidates it's how we all act it's how
Charlotte and I behave in the business
that will you know and how we talk about
other people how we talk about
candidates how we talk about
clients you know Behavior breeds
behavior and and and I think we we've
got to be so careful that we're living
our values and then the rest of the team
will do do that via candidate
conversations yeah I want to I want to
ask you as you're come to the end here
like how yeah how you cuz you clearly so
passionate about what you were just
talking about yeah how what you like
what you believe you both do that really
enables that to happen you know 90% of
the time um but Ju Just quickly I think
it's worth highlighting with what some
people like oh my God 2 hours before
like for every candidate right but like
I said you there's no way you'll be
doing that unless you see like net
positive personally I think something I
always remember um if someone you should
be connected with actually I think you
really get along he recruits in the fmcg
space and again we I remember when he
did like a training session with us we
were talking
about consist how to consistently
generate candidate referrals yeah and
where he's had the most success is
making sure the candidate experience is
world class for people that don't get a
job yeah and some of his biggest
customers have come from Abby didn't get
a job at Brew dog that I was in the
process of before however she then went
to honest burgers and she's someone
bring them up again but anyway she then
went there and was like Rich didn't help
me get a job however world class
experience Rich can you help me at hbers
I'm assuming you got a lot of stories
like that we got look we've being honest
we've tried a load of refer a friend and
do we have a load of people people that
we've paid out the bloody vouchers to no
but I think actually there's loads of um
just it's happened you know without our
knowledge just saying oh so and so Tommy
to speak to you so and so Tommy speak to
you that happens so many times a day to
all of us yeah so like for those of you
listening what I take from that is like
like you said it would be really easy to
Ping out a survey aby's got a new job
she's got you know some uh 68 people
merch like they've sorted her out all
that Abby like would you recommend to a
friend or colleague oh yeah absolutely
but it's the people that aren't you know
fortunate to get the job like what
experience you cring for those people CU
they could be your biggest detractors
yeah and your biggest promoters and we
don't always get it right yeah and but
it's how you react when you don't get it
right and what we do you know we could
say him you know they don't know
you know and actually we don't we obsess
over the ones that we don't get right
and that's what changes process and
that's what changes experience so with
all this being so important that's what
I just wanted to AR and get your
thoughts on is like as you as you grow I
know you're very much focused now on
getting the most out of your existing
people rather than worried about
headcount and stuff but still there's a
lot more like I feel like the stuff that
you've spoken about today people
listening are going to feel a lot more
confident to be able to roll out for to
be consistently executed if they like
have a smaller team and you know they
can influence it by proximity maybe
whereas like you're you're probably
beyond that now so what you were talking
about how you know you you talk like um
how you and Charlotte talk people lit
like talk to me about how you feel like
you enable those to be the standards
yeah like how they how those how they've
become the minimum standards cuz there's
a lot that you've spoken about which I
kind of like you said you lose sleepover
cuz it only takes one person yeah to be
like I'm not I'm not going to I'm
not going to do that today I'll just I'm
sure Abby won't know like do you know
what I mean that that the likel that
happening is more and more yeah and I
think look the culture in a business is
created by the people operating it and
we're you know Charlotte and I are
always conscious of that we've got to do
what we said we're going to do and we've
got to live and breathe those values and
we do have look whether people think
values are a load of or not um they
work for us and when we've got and they
work for the team the team get excited
about them we reward them we talk about
them you know we um highlight them all
our conferences and meetings and we have
little crappy awards for you know the
value Master of the week and so they're
alive you know in the business um and we
you know we take the piss out of each
other it's not very expert is it one of
our Val is expert um so you know they
they're alive and I think that the hey
you got to recruit the right people who
share those in the first place but then
because we're not teaching old dog new
tricks you know we're not taking people
from
having bad habits we're creating habits
so they're learning a totally new skill
when they come to us because they coming
from operations then that's when we've
had real success um whether I should say
it or not when it hasn't worked out when
we've taken people from other
recruitment
businesses and because it's too hard to
unpick yeah I'm not surprised some the
habits yeah because the people that
you're Hing are coming they've got the
hospitality in Industry context but
they're coming entirely open-minded with
no evidence on how recruitment should be
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's a blank
canvas in terms of recruitment so why
would they now do it any other way yeah
um how do you like I I do understand the
probably lead Domino to having those
standards consistently being met is
hiring the right people yes is probably
the lead so with you being
so how how do you uncover people the
Align with your values in the interview
process um I feel that's I feel like
that's hard yeah it's hard and you kind
of always think God how can we gock up
recruitment as recruiters um like I
think you've got to have a really robust
process we we part of our process is
they have to present on for 10 minutes
on anything they want anything they're
passionate about oh and that shows loads
of you know we've had really fun stuff
really weird stuff what stage is that up
um second or third depending on whether
they've met both of us or but
everything's face to face um
and yeah God there's a lot so much good
feeling goes into recruitment isn't
there but um hopefully we we've also you
know got some we've had some you know
proper recruitment training in terms of
Competency Based right okay you know do
you exhibit these values and and and
talking to people so we'd probably spend
you know I might spend an hour with
somebody Charlotte might spend an hour
with someone the team gets involved um
and then they present something 10
minutes on whatever wacky thing they
want to present on but then there's
always a bit good feeling right
yeah so what are you going into next
year then
mhm you know you have intentions to keep
growing the the important business
numbers we can say revenue revenue what
what are you like being laser focused on
like what are you and both you and
Charlotte got really top of mind you
said you had a strategy day recently
like what are the things that are really
top of mind that you're really going to
double down on stay close to um MPS
client NPS I I feel as though this the
tables we've spent the last couple of
years really focusing on candidates and
I feel as though you know that's I'm
sure that's um other businesses are
finding that that now we really need to
lay the focus down on our on our client
experience and kind of obsess over that
for a bit so C experience uh and fill
rate look fill rate is a what however
you look at fill rate there's no
downside to to it so if you can improve
that like know like said I said before
if you there's um a negative behavior
attached to really pushing a certain kpi
for example CV Zend um but with fill
rate there's no negative behavior if you
really push that it's only net positive
yeah so true that's actually really is
one of those metrics that's so true yeah
and so we're going to really focus on
that we're going to you know focus on
how we negotiate exclusivity um and how
we get that fill rate from 45 to 60
without reduction in job number
so that's the big that's the Trap that
took us nine hours nine hours just to
walk out with those two things job to
fill ratio is yeah I love that obviously
there's so many things that affect fill
rate yeah you know your consultant
training your well everything everything
affects fill rate doesn't it yeah there
there's a lot yeah but I do you are
right I think it's a great Allstar
metric isn't it yeah I hope so and it's
weird it's something that we don't
discuss with clients because you sound
right if you only fill 45% of the
jobs you get it sounds if you only
feel
um so it's not really a metric that we
we discuss with clients but I know that
we're significantly great you know
better at it than some of the businesses
that I've taken the metric from um but
yeah it feels like our internal Nar
right now yeah like we've we've help
some
companies like that's been like a metric
that they really wanted to improve of
training yeah when we're doing Discovery
calls and identifying those pay like for
a lot of these people it's like 15% yeah
job to is a job to fill ratio okay that
makes me feel good I mean that's like
we're with like 45 different recruitment
companies and I'm not saying all that
but like quite a few times it's been
around 15 20% and they want to get that
up from a mental health of Your
consultant's Capacity as well I mean
look that I'm always conscious that when
we fill 45% of our roles it means we
don't fill 55% of them and I you can't
analyze one without the other you've got
to find out why you're not filling the
55% and that um the mental challenge of
doing 55% of your work and it
not leading to anything is depressing
and I don't you know I want to level
that out for the Consultants yeah but I
think also I know you're saying you may
not want to shout from the rooftops that
we our fi rate is 45% but if you're
communicating to if you're able to
articulate to uh potential clients and
customers like this is the evidence that
we've gathered so far as to why job to
the job to fill ratio is normally this
if we Implement these things or get
really good at this with you yeah it
should actually mean that you know 70%
of the time we like we're going to be
successful for you yeah so like if
you're really thinking about that you're
only going to be able to find things
that then you can use that in your
process right like if this is why we
need to have Discovery call this is why
we do this this is why this is important
to us because this is the benefit for
you yeah yeah and it is laying out you
know back to your um challenge about
your process is laying out and setting
an expectation like keep seeing on
LinkedIn no one cares about your process
no one and they don't it's true they you
I don't think they do but I think you've
got to set expectations and say we're
going to do this we're going to you know
we need to we need another 40 minutes if
your time to talk about the Ines of the
role we need because that's we know from
our measures that that is the best
possible chance of us faing yeah no one
no one I don't it depend it depends on
the framing like no one cares about your
process Abby if you're talking about
your process just because it's your
process and it's process yeah and I do
care about your process if you're saying
listen to like this is our process
because it gives this is how it benefits
you it's just the framing right yeah and
it is just unframing that is I think as
a business we I'm really conscious that
we never we're selfless so whenever
we're talking to a candidate or a client
it's always got to be we've got to act
in their best interest not our own and
any conversation that we're having if we
start talking about oh we need to get
that interview in earlier we need to um
this needs to happen and it's in it
selfish it's about us wanting to hit a
Target or Revenue we it yeah yeah
AB it's been a pleasure honestly love
the way you approaching building your
business like I I could speak about this
a lot I I really enjoyed that so
hopefully everyone listening I think
there's loads of takeaways there
definitely things about process whether
that be meeting cadences Discovery calls
the team will be laughing that I'm
coming on to talk about process no I I
think honestly there's so many things
out and I think kudos to you keep keep
doing what you're doing and like oh yeah
I just I just love the waya approaching
your growing your recruitment business
so thank you thank you what a pleasure
thanks very much